مرحباً، أهلاً وسهلاً بالجميع في الدرس. اسمي ديفيد براون. هذا درس في قواعد اللغة. مرحباً. أهلاً بكم. أهلاً بكم في الدرس. نورما (Nūrmā)، أهلاً بكِ. مرحباً. شكراً لك. كيف حالك؟ أنا بخير. كيف حالك أنت؟ أنا بخير جداً. شكراً لك.
نورما، هل قضيتِ عطلة نهاية أسبوع جيدة؟ نعم، قضيتُ* عطلة نهاية أسبوع جيدة مع عائلتي.
عظيم. ممتاز. هل قضيتِ وقتاً مع، لديكِ ابن، أليس كذلك؟ اسمه خوسيه بابلو (Khūsīh Bāblū)؟ نعم. هو دائماً يحاول* أن يلعب معي. لذا لا أستطيع فعل أي شيء في المنزل سوى اللعب معه.
حسناً، يبدو ذلك حقاً عطلة نهاية أسبوع جيدة. في هذا الدرس يا نورما، سنتحدث عن عطلات نهاية الأسبوع وسنتحدث عن الأفعال المنتظمة والأفعال الشاذة، والفرق بينهما.
وكيف نصف عطلات نهاية أسبوعنا باستخدام النطق وكذلك ظروف الترتيب. دعنا نقرأ هذه الأهداف هنا. هل ترين الشاشة بوضوح؟ نعم، أستطيع رؤيتها.
حسناً، عظيم. لنبدأ بقراءة هذا الجزء هنا. هل يمكنكِ قراءة هذا السطر لي؟ التحدث عن الماضي. ترين جميع أفعال الماضي مثل washed, went, ate.
لوصف الأحداث المنتهية. حسناً. والتالي؟ ثم الترتيب التالي. رتبي قصتك. استخدمي كلمات خاصة. First, then, next. After that, finally، لسرد الأشياء بالترتيب الصحيح.
ليكن صوتك واضحاً، تدربي على نطق نهايات الأفعال المنتهية بـ -ed بشكل صحيح. حسناً. واكتبي قصتك. اكتبي فقرة قصيرة، من ثلاث إلى خمس جمل عن حدث شخصي ماضٍ.
حسناً، عظيم. إذاً هذه هي أهدافنا لدرس اليوم.
نرى أن لدينا الماضي والحاضر والمستقبل. لدينا تصريفات مختلفة والعديد من الطلاب يجدون صعوبة كبيرة في زمن الماضي لسببين: الأول، هناك طرق مختلفة لنطق الأفعال التي تنتهي بـ ED.
وأيضاً لأن هناك العديد من أفعال الماضي الشاذة، ربما أكثر من 200 فعل ماضٍ شاذ نحتاج إلى حفظها.
لذا نرى أن بنية الفعل الأساسية هي بشكل أساسي الفعل + ed. وهذا هو الماضي البسيط. وهذا ينجح في معظم الأوقات. لذا نضيف فقط ed إلى نهايته. على سبيل المثال، لدينا finish وفي الماضي، تصبح finished.
فعل أساسي، ثم الباقي. إليكِ مثال هنا. هل يمكنكِ قراءة هذا المثال لي؟
الحاضر، watch TV، الماضي، yesterday, I watched* a movie.
حسناً. جيد. سنتدرب على بعض النطق أكثر قليلاً. قد يكون من الصعب على الناطقين الأصليين بالإسبانية نطق صوت ch في watched.
لكنكِ ستتقنينه. لا تقلقي.
وهكذا نرى مثالاً كهذا أيضاً. They play soccer. ثم في الماضي تصبح They played soccer. ويمكنكِ سماع نطق مختلف لهذا.
في الأول، صوت /t/، وفي الثاني، صوت /d/. ثم إليكِ مثال آخر. هل يمكنكِ قراءة هذا لي؟
She cooks dinner الماضي she cooked dinner last night.
عظيم. إذاً قواعد الإملاء الأساسية هي أننا نحتاج إلى إضافة ed إلى نهاية الفعل.
هناك بعض الأحيان التي نحتاج فيها إلى تغيير y إلى i ثم إضافة ed. على سبيل المثال، study تصبح studied أو cry،
تصبح cried مع ied.
ولكن في معظم الأحيان، ستضيفين فقط -ed إلى نهاية الفعل لجعله في صيغة الماضي.
حسناً. لنستمر. هل لديكِ أي أسئلة لي قبل أن نستمر؟
لا، فقط أردت أن أقول، كما ذكرتَ، الأمر صعب. هذا أحد أصعب الأجزاء عندما بدأت تعلم اللغة الإنجليزية، زمن الماضي بسبب جزء النطق ذاك.
لكننا نحاول التدرب مراراً وتكراراً.
أتفهم ذلك. ومن الطبيعي أن نشعر ببعض التوتر عندما نحاول القيام بأشياء صعبة.
حتى الآن، أداؤكِ جيد جداً جداً، استثنائي. لذا لا تقلقي يا نورما.
حسناً. إذاً أحد الأشياء الصعبة، كما ذكرتِ، هو معرفة كل هذه الأفعال الشاذة.
لذا نحتاج إلى حفظها. لا يوجد حقاً مفر من حفظ هذه الأفعال المختلفة.
بالطبع، نحتاج إلى استخدامها في سياقها، لكننا حقاً بحاجة إلى حفظ كل هذه الأفعال الماضية الشاذة.
لدينا بعض الأمثلة هنا. الماضي من go هو went... الماضي من eat هو ate.
الماضي من have هو had* الماضي من see هو saw، الماضي من drink هو drank، الماضي من make هو made.
نطق جيد. الماضي من buy هو ماذا؟ Bought.
أوه، حسناً. وماذا عن هذا؟
الماضي من wake up هو woke up.
حسناً. ثم نحتاج إلى تذكر هذه التصريفات للفعل to be.
لذا ليس لدينا فقط أفعال منتظمة، بل أحياناً تبدو مختلفة تماماً في تصريفات الماضي.
لذا لدينا be ثم was أو were للفعل to be.
حسناً. هذه مجرد عينة صغيرة من الأفعال الشاذة.
أوصي حقاً بأنه عندما يكون لديكِ وقت، حاولي إيجاد قوائم لهذه الأفعال الشاذة واستخدامها.
فكري فيها كلما تحدثتِ عن الماضي. تأكدي من أنكِ تصرفينها بشكل صحيح.
دعنا نختبر بعضاً منها. وأعتقد أننا يمكن أن نستمر لأنكِ تبدين أداءً جيداً حقاً.
الماضي من go هو went، الماضي من have هو had، الماضي من drink هو drank.
جيد. الماضي من buy هو... Bought?
رائع. حسناً. نطقكِ تحسن كثيراً حقاً. أنا معجب جداً.
شكراً لك.
حسناً. إذاً لدينا ثلاث طرق مختلفة لنطق هذه الأفعال التي تنتهي بـ -ed.
وقد تدربنا على هذا بشكل ضمني من قبل، لكنني أعتقد أنه من المفيد حقاً فهم بعض هذه القواعد أيضاً.
لدينا ثلاثة أصوات مختلفة نصدرها عندما ننطق الأفعال التي تنتهي بـ -ed.
أحدها هو صوت /t/ هنا بأسنانك.
والآخر هو صوت /t/ ويكون خلف الأسنان مباشرة هناك في الحافة السنخية (al-ḥāffah as-sinkhiyyah)، هكذا تسمى.
هناك ننطق صوت /d/. ثم لدينا صوت /ɪd/.
إذاً يبدأ هذا بالصوت الجهوري هنا حيث تأتي الحركات (أصوات العلة).
ثم ينتهي بصوت /d/ في سقف فمك.
لذا لدينا /d/ و /ɪd/ ويعتمد ذلك على الحرف الساكن الأخير.
إذاً الحرف الساكن الأخير في watch، على سبيل المثال، هو ch كرري كرري كرري.
هكذا. جيد جداً. حسناً. إذاً لدينا watched? هذا صعب جداً.
Watched? Watched? Watched? Watched? جيد جداً.
عظيم. و look تصبح. Looked.
Looks جيد جداً. Stop هي. Stopped. صحيح. إذاً ليس لدينا صوت يبدأ هنا بصوت /t/ المهموس في النهاية.
ثم لدينا صوت /d/. تذكري في سقف الفم.
إذاً لدينا play وفي الماضي تصبح، تذكري /d/. كرري بعدي.
جيد جداً. Played. Played.
جيد. هذا؟ Opened.
عظيم. وهذا؟
Lived. رائع. مثالي. مدهش.
إذاً يمكنكِ حفظ هذه القواعد هنا.
يمكنكِ تعلمها بعد بعض الوقت من مجرد التدرب عليها وسماعها لفترة طويلة.
ولكن إذا تذكرتِ أنه إذا كان الحرف الساكن الأخير هو L, V, N, G, M, R, Z, أو J (الأصوات الجهورية)،
فسينتج عن ذلك صوت /d/ في النهاية.
أهم قاعدة يجب تذكرها هي أنه عندما يكون الحرف الساكن الأخير "t" أو "d"،
فإننا سننطق /ɪd/ في النهاية.
لذا لدينا wanted والحرف الساكن الأخير هو "t".
wanted، إنها wanted. الحرف الساكن الأخير في need هو ماذا؟ Needed.
إذاً هو D. الحرف الساكن الأخير هو D. لذا فهي needed و decided.
Decided. مثالي. حسناً. إذاً نضيف مقطعاً إضافياً مع صوت /ɪd/ ذاك في النهاية.
أعتقد أننا يمكن أن نستمر. كيف تشعرين؟
هل يبدو هذا سهلاً لكِ أم أنه صعب قليلاً أم ماذا تعتقدين؟
أعتقد أنكِ تبدين أداءً رائعاً.
لا، أشعر بالارتياح.